laut der nasa ist das eine der
tiefgreifendsten entdeckung der
menschheit neue bilder des personals
rovers enthüllen nämlich jetzt eines der
spannendsten rätsel um den roten
planeten
sie offenbaren die vergangenheit des
c-zero kraters demnach war der mars in
der vergangenheit warm und feucht genug
um einen wasserkreislauf zu unterstützen
stoßen wir also bald auf außerirdisches
leben klicks und science and future hier
gibt es drei mal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
diese entdeckung ist wirklich
spektakulär und sie macht außerirdisches
leben auf dem mars noch ein stückchen
wahrscheinlich ja die große frage die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit endlich beantworten wollen
lautet wie wasserreich und damit
lebensfreundlich war der rote planet der
vergangenheit wirklich es gibt einige
hinweise darauf dass der mars auf jeden
fall mal wasser reicher gewesen sein
muss als heutzutage fachleute haben alte
flusstäler deltas und tonminerale
aufgespürt die genau das nahelegen doch
trotz intensiver forschung ist bis heute
unklar ob es auf dem roten planeten
möglicherweise sogar sehen und
langlebige ozeane gab oder doch nur
vorübergehende sturzfluten verursacht
durch schmelzwasser oder kurzzeitigen
starkregen doch der nasa rover person
evans hat jetzt bilder aus dem giro
krater geschickt die die fachwelt in
aufregung versetzen die aufnahmen werfen
ein ganz neues licht darauf wie sich das
klima auf unserem nachbarplaneten in der
vergangenheit entwickelt haben könnte
und sie machen die existenz von
außerirdischen leben auf dem mars noch
ein stückchen wahrscheinlich alle
spannenden infos zu diesem
sensationsfund der nasa gibt es jetzt
hier praktisch zum science and future so
klingt der jubel des nasa
wissenschaftlers nicolas mangold das ist
die schlüssel beobachtung die uns ein
für alle mal bestätigt dass es einen see
und ein flussdelta am see zero krater
gab die rede ist vom leo krater wo der
nasa rover person wir uns im februar
diesen jahres 2021 gelandet war
heutzutage ist der staubtrocken kaum
vorstellbar also dass es hier also mal
wasser gegeben haben soll der zerotracer
1 ausgetrocknet dass sie also und ein
ort der zuvor noch niemals genauer unter
die lupe genommen wurde es handelt sich
um eine 45 kilometer große senke und
möglicherweise hat hier bis vor rund 3,7
milliarden jahren ein großer see gelegen
doch ist das wirklich so haben die
fachleute mit dieser vermutung recht aus
dem orbit ließ sich diese frage nicht
eindeutig beantworten zum einsatz des
personals rovers sagt der nasa
mitarbeiter thomas zu buchen die seo
krater ist der perfekte ort um nach
zeichen vergangenen lebens zu suchen so
können wir verstehen wieder maß einmal
war und warum er nun so ist wie er ist
eine us-studie hatte vor dem start vom
person wir uns bestätigt dass das
angepeilte untersuchungsgebiet auf dem
roten planeten gut gewählt ist im
bereich des c-zero kraters zeichnen sich
nämlich höchstwahrscheinlich reste eines
einstigen flussdeltas ab und das ist für
die suche nach spuren von leben
natürlich äußerst erfolgversprechend
auch modellsimulationen machen große
hoffnungen denn sie offenbaren dass der
fluss im zero krater mögliche
mikrobielle lebensform auf der
marsoberfläche 1 fort getragen haben
könnte und sie sich somit geschützt
unter den sedimenten abgelagert haben
dazu der forscher mattila porträts
sollen bei der mission die ersten proben
entstehen die für untersuchungen vom
mars zur erde gebracht werden das ist
sehr aufregend denn es könnte sich damit
die chance ergeben einblicke in die
entstehung von leben auf einem anderen
planeten zu gewinnen und somit auch in
die frage was leben überhaupt ist
insgesamt acht jahre lang haben die
forschungsteams der nasa an dem
insgesamt 2,2 milliarden euro teuren
mars-rover gebaut sein name ist
hoffentlich programm denn person evans
bedeutet übersetzt so viel wie
durchhaltevermögen der rover hat die
größe eines kleinen autos und ist rund
1000 kilogramm schwer es ist der fünfte
und bislang technisch komplizierteste
mars-rover der usa denn nicht nur alle
negativen sondern auch positiven
erfahrungen die die nasa in den
vorherigen missionen gesammelt hatte
wurden bei der planung und dem bau von
personen berücksichtigt denn er verfügt
nicht nur über einen roboterarm und 20
kameras sondern auch über einen mini
hubschrauber der ja schon rekorde
erreicht hat und jetzt kurz nach seiner
landung gelang wir uns also gleich ein
volltreffer
das internationale forschungsteam hat
kameraaufnahmen und multi spektral
bilder des rovers ausgewertet die in den
westlichen teil des kraters zeigen zu
finden sind die riesige
gesteinsformationen die spannende
details offenbaren denn hier treten
verschiedene sedimentschichten zutage
wodurch die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler spannende rückschlüsse
ziehen können die struktur und abfolge
der sedimentschichten verraten nämlich
die wasserstände im kratersee und nicht
nur das auch die fließgeschwindigkeiten
der zuflüsse können so offenbart werden
die fachleute kommen so zu einer
spektakulären erkenntnis demnach gab es
im zero krater tatsächlich einen
riesigen see bis vor rund 3,7 milliarden
jahren war dieser demnach mehr oder
weniger dauerhaft geflutet davon zeugen
feinkörnige ablagerungen in den unteren
segment schichten der zero krater auf
dem mars wurde zudem von einem kleineren
fluss gespeist wie es in der aktuellen
studie heißt eine super spannende
erkenntnis auch für die fachwelt selbst
dazu sagt einer der beteiligten
wissenschaftler benjamin weiß der rover
hat damit schon einmal eine der großen
fragen beantwortet ob dieser krater
einst einsehbar bevor wir dort gelandet
sind und dies nun bestätigen können
stand dies immer in frage laut der
aktuellen studie ist es somit also
belegt dass das klima auf dem mars in
dieser frühzeit feucht und warm genug
für gewässer war und damit hat er
möglicherweise
damals auch leben beherbergt doch dann
muss es dem forschungsteam zufolge einen
dramatischen wandel gegeben haben der
lebensfreundliche feuchte planet hat
sich dann nämlich zu einem trockenen und
kalten wüstenplaneten verändert dazu der
nasa-forscher benjamin weiss zu dieser
zeit in der planeten geschichte muss
etwas sehr grundlegendes passiert sein
solch einen drastischen wandel legt die
analyse der sedimentschichten die
unteren schichten im zero delta bestehen
nämlich aus feinkörnigem material das
charakteristisch für gemächlich
fließende gewässer ist doch die oberen
schichten zeigen sich anders zu finden
sind die gigantische große felsblöcke
die teilweise meter groß und mehrere
tonnen schwer sind sie bestehen anders
als das meiste sediment im delta nicht
aus oliven und schicht silikaten sondern
aus kalzium armen führung szenen nach
ansicht der vorstellen stammen diese von
einem anderen ort möglicherweise gut 60
kilometer stromaufwärts des risikograd
das wie es in der aktuellen studie heißt
daraus schließen fachleute dass es
gewaltige sturzfluten auf dem roten
planeten gegeben haben muss die diese
tonnenschweren felsbrocken mitgerissen
haben bis zu 3000 kubikmeter wasser pro
sekunde muss den berechnungen zufolge in
den krater gestürzt sein denn nur solche
energiereichen sturzfluten können solche
gigantisch großen und schweren brocken
mitreißen die dann mit zug bis zu neun
metern pro sekunde den hang
hinuntergestürzt sein müssen in dieser
zeit muss sich das thema auf dem mars
gewaltig verändert haben der regen muss
hier sporadisch aber heftig gewesen sein
so wie es heutzutage in manchen
wüstengebieten dieser erde der fall ist
das feuchte milde und lebensfreundliche
klima auf dem roten planeten ging somit
zu ende das begann episoden mit heftigen
sturzfluten bis sich der master zu einem
kalten und trockenen wüstenplaneten
verwandelte was damals genau passierte
stellt die fachleute aber vor ein rätsel
doch passivieren es wird nicht aufgeben
so viel steht fest der plan sieht vor
dass der rover demnächst zu dem
ehemaligen flussdelta fahren wird um
dort bodenproben zu nehmen hier könnten
die sedimente aus dem ehemaligen spuren
von vor im leben im wasser enthalten
dazu die us-wissenschaftlerin tanja
bosak wir haben jetzt die möglichkeit
nach fossilien zu suchen diese
bodenproben sollen dann im jahr 2031 mit
hilfe einer weiteren raumsonde zur erde
zurückgebracht werden der ehemalige chef
des nasa mars programm scott hubbard
hatte proben vom roten planeten mal als
heiligen gral der mars wissenschaften
bezeichnet die fachleute jedenfalls sind
sicher dass providence uns auf der
intensiven suche nach leben einen großen
schritt nach vorne bringen wird wird uns
auf dem mars das blut ausgesaugt
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren bis
dann
bleibt dran